hi everyone it's jerry i have a fun game
to share with you
recently a friendly game was played
between judith polgar on the white end
and magnus carlson this took place in a
park in madrid during the final rest day
of the candidates tournament and
whenever two greats are at the board
it's always a fun game to have a look at
there's banter going on nice little
crowd let's dive in and see how this one
played out and how the world champ was
taken down in only 19 moves
came out of an open sicilian taimanov
and the first interesting point is right
about
move
number
12 right here
so white on move
e5
immediately throwing a punch to this
knight
big decision
in the game
knight takes g4s on board
considered one of the better moves is to
centralize
not go pawn hunting not allow open files
we'll see how this causes a great
inconvenience to black in the game
picking off the g4 pawn
reply to knight d5 best would be 94 kind
of juking the knight and eyeing up this
potential jump maybe opening up this
diagonal okay
not going to go too deep into these
lines it's only a three minute game by
the way so in the game it was knight
takes g4 taking advantage of this pin
rook g1 as the follow up
does unpin the pawn and now this threat
is actually there in a couple ways
the reply was knight h6
this is the only moment i'm really going
to draw some attention to and show some
lines
i did even though it is a 3-0 game i did
take a
a
little mini
lesson from this moment in the game so
uh if the pawn is
knocked out
the reply here best reply would be
bishop to g2
and
uh
if we if the bishop captures the bishop
this will be a big problem for black
notice the double attack
with the queen on g2 one of these will
soon fall
white is winning
and if instead of bishop takes bishop
bishop takes rook
we would have bishop takes rook and
white will be getting one of these two
uh soon enough white's going to be up a
piece but blacks does have some pawns
uh
one other line would be knight h2
that can be met with queen f4
and after bishop takes rook bishop takes
rook once more
black is in a spot where one of these
two miners will fall
final line
is this one right here i question queen
c6
that won't work out either
after bishop takes queen takes there's
rook g3
kicking the queen to f5 and now once
more we see this nice little
maneuver with the queen to d2
once more a double attack
to the brook and knight
white will be winning from this position
okay
black does not bite does not take a
second pawn instead
withdraws the knight
some more development
not caring to defend this pawn if the
pawn is captured
uh well
that's going to translate into another
open file
for the white pieces
black star has to find safe ground for
the king no g-pawn now there's a lot of
heat
down this king side of the board so
what was played is bishop to f8 not a
fun move to play at all under developing
but that was considered best
if you castle like this you're initially
i thought you're killed in this way
but even better is
rook takes g7
and this is leading to mate it's calling
for a matin five right now
with this sequence all you could do is
computer like moves
delaying mate like this
and soon enough we're gonna have mate
next move
three different mates
can't parry them all
okay what was played in the game bishop
f8
bishop e4
it's a fairly even position right here
until
black's
next move
rook c8
pop quiz
the only one of this video
can you spot judit's
killer move
feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
bishop to b6
and this is basically game over what's
the problem
if the bishop is captured
that's mate
there's no hiding on f8 there after that
underdeveloping move
and there is no safe square for the
queen
right she she needs she has a
responsibility to defend d7
so this was
this was missed what would have been
better instead of rook to c8 is to
initiate this exchange
um yeah this was also interesting for me
to
for me to see
i was thinking initially uh
you would recapture with the knight
eyeing up these squares but after knight
to f5 that's also a pretty good square
the computer says after this move
white should be doubling the pawns like
this
to not to keep this knight sidelined
that's considered best
all right
in the game it was rook c8
bishop b6
on board and the queen is toast and this
game is
this game is over out of momentum some
some more moves were played
out of momentum
but this game is long gone at this stage
after knight f5 knight e4 that's it
carlson extended his hand
in resigns after just these 19 moves so
uh just a fun game here between two
greats always nice to see
uh judit back at the board
she did retire in
2014 so whenever we get to see another
game by her it's always
for me at least i like to
check it out
anyhow feel free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
yeah found a little fun
that's all for now take care bye